[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I wanted to answer a question from
one of my newsletter readers Francis who
wants to start a shoe stall and one of
my advice on how to get started and get
the money to kind of launch this
business
so Francis thanks for the question I'm
always a big believer in not spending
money till you're making money and
sometimes you know these little retail
shops or stalls can be really pricey so
what I would recommend doing is
partnering up with somebody who already
has a stall in the location that you're
looking for and selling something else
to not shoes and you just take over a
little portion of it and hopefully you
don't have to pay for it I try to
negotiate a way where you can maybe
share the profits that come in from it
or you can help promote their business a
little bit as well try to start the
business without spending money you know
when you're making money you can search
for any money but anybody can spend
money so you want to try to find a way
to be resourceful and start bringing in
the money without having to spend money
to get customers coming in so cash is
king at the start so start off a little
stall with somebody else see it first
off it is for you right people have
great business ideas I think they're
gonna be awesome at doing something and
then it turns out that was a terrible
idea they didn't want to do it at all
and they're not really good at it so why
not test it out on a small scale see if
you like it see if you're good at it see
if it's something you want to continue
doing before spending a lot of money
investing into something that you know
you may not enjoy doing so start small
test it then I would try to see you know
get educated on the types of shoes that
you're gonna be able to sell the hours
you know which stall might be a good
location for you so you can test all
these things on a small scale and build
up your audience so anybody who comes
and starts to buy try to get their
information try to you know put them on
an email list so you can let them know
when you open up your own location so
when you do open up your own place your
own stall just for yourself you're good
to have an audience because you know you
know that market delivers for you and
you can email people to say hey you know
we woke up we've opened up our new
location much bigger than we had before
come on check
and you've done it all in a low-risk way
it takes a little bit more time but your
chances of success are much higher and
the chance of you losing and burning a
lot of money also you know go down a lot
as well so hopefully that helps Frances
good luck I'm really excited to hear how
it turns out if you guys have any
suggestions for Frances you know please
leave a comment below be great to hear
from you and if you liked the video I
really appreciate it you can give it a
thumbs up I love seeing those come in so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode
[Music]
you